Having your ordinary life unceremoniously
change forever without a moment’s notice is
something that people can often find themselves
hoping for. Anything to break life’s monotony
and change circumstances to make them more
interesting. Although, when that change comes
in the form of being trapped in an endless Ikea
outlet, it’s not exactly the different kind of
circumstances that people usually hope for.
That was the situation that had befallen
Winston not too long ago. What started as a
simplistic, straightforward shopping trip with
the goal of purchasing some affordable, stylish
Swedish furniture had resulted in him having
to adopt a completely different lifestyle.
You see, Winston was one of an untold number
of people to have an encounter with SCP-3008,
better known colloquially as the Infinite Ikea.
Appearing as an ordinary store, those entering
through the doors of SCP-3008 find themselves
in an unending labyrinth of aisles upon aisles
filled with flatpack homeware. It can be quite
the system shock, of course, especially
when people that find themselves inside
the Infinite Ikea learn that there’s no way to
escape, even by retracing their steps back the
way they came. Doing so, they’ll only be met
with the disheartening realization that the
entrance isn’t where it was upon their arrival.
Now, at first, learning that you’ve lost your
entire life and are doomed to spend the rest of
your days inside a limitless Ikea is admittedly
a lot to take in. Your friends, family, job, and
all your worldly possessions are now unreachable,
and everyone back home might likely
spend many years wondering what
happened to you. But it’s not all bad news.
As previously mentioned, Winston wasn’t the
only one to find himself in this predicament. Over
the years, countless people have found their way
inside the Infinite Ikea. Given how expansive
the interior of the never-ending store was,
there has never been a way to know for certain
exactly how many people have come to reside
within SCP-3008. But it's enough to populate
the number of small settlements that these
survivors have been able to establish inside.
By innovatively repurposing the materials around
them, those that have found themselves to be
new denizens of SCP-3008. Imagine whole towns
constructed from chairs and tables that have
been used as building materials to provide a
place of sanctuary to those that need it when
they first arrive in the Infinite Ikea. Sure,
it takes a pretty big adjustment to this new
lifestyle. But luckily, SCP-3008 provides for
its inhabitants by automatically replenishing
the food within its canteen. Naturally,
it only offers items that are on the Ikea menu,
but that’s at least a consistent source of food
and nutrition for those dwelling in its aisles.
With food already taken care of, people inside
SCP-3008 didn’t even need to work. That was the
strangest part that Winston found himself having
to adapt to when he first got to the settlement
of ‘Cookware’ named after the nearby sign that
hung from the ceiling nearby, denoting one of
many departments of the store. It was odd to
him how friendly everyone was, how much
the people trapped inside SCP-3008, cut
off from the outside world forever seemed happy.
There were many who’d been there for the longest
that even claimed it was a better way of life than
out there in the ‘real world’. Inside the Ikea,
there was a strong sense of community. Settlements
helped each other out with construction, and,
because everyone was provided for, no-one had
any need for selfishness or greed. After all,
there was plenty of food to go around and
money had no relevance – ironic given that they
were all living inside a huge furniture store.
Witnessing all that helped Winston to adapt to
this new life inside SCP-3008, and made him feel
a lot better about being in this predicament. The
only real thing anyone inside the Infinite Ikea
had to worry about was the threat of the Staff.
These were the tall, faceless humanoids with
elongated arms and legs that roamed the aisles of
the furniture store while wearing distinctive Ikea
uniforms. Most of the time, they remained docile,
paying the human survivors little attention.
That is, until the fluorescent lights above
dimmed, signaling the beginning of night
time. The Staff usually became aggressive,
repeating the ominous phrase “The store is
now closed, please exit the building,” and
attacking anyone they came into contact with.
Thanks to their ingenuity, the survivors in the
Ikea had constructed barriers around their
settlements to keep the Staff out. And that
did the trick, repelling the faceless employees
come night. But little did anyone inside SCP-3008
realize that simple barricades wouldn’t stop an
entirely new threat from entering the store to
disrupt their peaceful way of life. For outside
the Infinite Ikea, something wicked was stirring.
Meanwhile, at a facility belonging to the
SCP Foundation, a researcher by the name
of Corbin Donnel had recently been reassigned
to SCP-035. Also known as the Possessive Mask,
this white porcelain mask could shift between a
comedy grin or a tragic frown. It also had the
nasty trait of being an evil psychic artifact
that could manipulate anyone around it into
placing the mask over their face. At that point,
SCP-035 would take full control of its wearer,
making them into a host for the mask
itself. So, would you like to take a guess
as to what was happening to Researcher Donnel?
The voice in his head, that persuasive whisper,
it wouldn’t leave him alone. All day long, it
was there, but whenever Corbin was near SCP-035,
it got even louder. And as the days he
was studying the Possessive Mask went on,
the whisper became a shout. The screams to
put on the mask were taunting him, keeping
him awake at night, tormenting him all through the
waking day. Until, eventually, he’d had enough.
Given that SCP-035 produced a corrosive, black
substance that usually melted anything around it,
the mask had to be periodically taken out of its
containment case so that the container housing it
could be replaced. And it was during one of these
transfers that Researcher Donnel calmly swept in,
pushed away the guards taking it out of its melted
case before they could place it in a new one. The
aggression from the Researcher caught the security
personnel by surprise, as did what he did next.
Not caring what the Possessive Mask would do
to him, Corbin lifted the white porcelain to
his face. He wasn’t even aware that the
containment breach alarms were sounding,
all that noise sank into the background as the
psychic voice in his head got louder than it
had ever been before. There wasn’t even so much as
a split second awareness from Researcher Donnel of
the searing pain as the dark sludge oozing from
the mask made contact with his skin, melting his
face as he wore SCP-035. By that point, it was
already too late. The Possessive Mask had full
control. Corbin’s body wasn’t his own any more.
Although it still moved, walking quickly out of
the room and through the halls of the Foundation
facility, the researcher beneath was already dead.
There was only SCP-035, piloting
its newest host to freedom.
Of course, while a containment breach was
still an urgent matter, the Foundation knew
that SCP-035’s biggest weakness was itself. The
black secretion that poured out of the Possessive
Mask would melt anything it came into contact
with, and would ultimately cause the body of its
host to melt into nothing. Once this happened,
it would be far easier to re-contain SCP-035,
someone would merely have to carefully pick it
up and place it back in the containment case.
However, SCP-035 knew this too. The mask
itself was cunning, it hadn’t just picked
Researcher Donnel at random to be its new
vehicle, it wanted him specifically because
of his previous posting. Before he had worked with
SCP-035, Corbin had been stationed to observe any
potential changes at the entrance of… SCP-3008.
As it stayed firmly on the researcher’s face,
using him to carry itself out of the
Foundation site it had been trapped in,
SCP-035 was scouring the remnants of Corbin’s
mind. It used its innate psychic abilities to
plunder the depths of his brain, looking for
information. The location of SCP-3008 was right
there, stored away safely in Researcher Donnel’s
memories. As was the way to get there. And on
top of that, the reason SCP-035 had taken such
an interest in making it to the Infinite Ikea.
During the Foundation’s many years
of study and exploration of SCP-3008,
they had come to learn that not all of the
survivors inside the Infinite Ikea had originated
from the same universe. The current theory was
that entrances to the endless furniture store
existed simultaneously in multiple realities,
meaning that the people now living alongside
each other inside SCP-3008 were actually from
varying different worlds across the multiverse.
Now, if you were incredibly cunning,
incredibly clever, and incredibly sick
of being held captive by the Foundation, then
perhaps you could figure out a way to navigate
your way through the Infinite Ikea. You could
enter through the front door in one universe,
and then exit into another. And of course, that
was what the Possessive Mask was planning to do.
As it approached the main entrance of SCP-3008,
the black gunge leaking out of the mask had almost
destroyed what was left of Researcher Corbin
Donnel. It wiped more of the corrosive secretion
onto the guards stationed at the Infinite
Ikea, melting through them as SCP-035 made
its way inside. First things first, the mask knew
it had to find itself a new body to pilot, before
Corbin’s expired… and it didn’t take long for
the Possessive Mask to happen across an unwitting
candidate between the aisles of flatpack tables.
At around the same time that this was happening,
Winston – having long since gotten used to the
rhythm of life inside SCP-3008 – was on his
way to the food court. He knew the route
by heart now, and as he strolled closer,
he was pondering over what he’d help himself to
today from the menu. But it was while making his
way there that he noticed something; or rather,
he noticed not noticing something that he usually
did. There were no Staff anywhere around.
Although they didn’t pay the survivors any
mind during the day, when the lights of the Ikea
were on, Winston knew that the Staff members
were always present. There were usually a couple
milling about the aisles he had to pass in order
to get from the settlement of Cookware to the food
hall. But today, there were none. And while this
wouldn’t usually be any cause for alarm, it kept
playing on Winston’s mind as he sat down to eat
his plate of Swedish meatballs. He’d been inside
SCP-3008 for such a long time that he’d become
accustomed to the routine of living there, and
the absence of the Staff immediately stuck out
as something that was out of its usual place.
Finishing his food, Winston asked around,
talking with his fellow residents of the Infinite
Ikea, asking if any of them had encountered any
of the tall, faceless Staff members on
their way to get their meals. Each and
every one of them that he asked, from varying
different settlements, all answered the same,
that they hadn’t spotted any Staff all day. As
much as they were a minor threat to the human
beings living in the Infinite Ikea, the absence of
the store’s only other residents kept playing on
Winston’s mind. Whatever was going on, the Staff
seemingly vanishing couldn’t mean anything good,
and so he decided to venture out into the
aisles to figure out what exactly was going on.
What he found was unlike anything that
anyone had seen in SCP-3008 before.
It took Winston several long and uneventful
hours to catch even a momentary glimpse of
a Staff member, he almost felt like someone
trekking through a forest looking to get a
sighting of Bigfoot, or some other elusive urban
legend. But as the third hour became the fourth,
he spotted a hint of movement between the aisles.
Following at a safe distance, listening out for
the slightest sounds, Winston couldn’t help
but think he detected the noise of something
heavy being dragged along the store floor.
Peeking out from between the aisles, he saw
them. A huge group of Staff members were huddled
in a display dining room, only there was something
different about them all. They all still retained
their recognizable tall and humanoid shapes,
with long disproportionally long limbs. But
there was something smeared over the Staff,
a dark, oily black substance that seemed
to melt through the floor as it dripped
off them. From his hiding place, Winston soon
saw where that substance had originated from.
The thing being dragged across the floor was
another Staff member, looking more normal than the
rest. One of the others, covered in the corrosive
sludge, was gripping it by the collar of its Ikea
polo shirt and bringing it through the group.
Meanwhile, the ‘ordinary’ creature was thrashing
and flailing its lengthy arms around, trying to
get free. It was dragged up to a Staff member
in the middle of the group, which turned around
and shocked Winston at the strange sight of it.
This Staff member, evidently the leader, had
a face. Or rather, it was wearing a mask.
SCP-035 was now affixed firmly to the slender,
faceless being, its expression locked in a wide
grin that seemed to convey a twisted sense
of glee. Its black secretion didn’t seem to
be affecting its new host in the same way it
usually did, the body of the Staff member it
was now piloting didn’t seem to dissolve. As
the uncorrupted Staff creature was presented
to the masked leader, SCP-035 compelled its
newfound followers to restrain their prisoner.
The workers within SCP-3008 didn’t have much
in the way of their own free will or even
personalities to speak of. They did, however, seem
to share some sort of connection to each other,
a hive mind of sorts. So, presented with a
powerful psychic force like the Possessive Mask,
the entity had been able to not only take over
one Staff member as its new host, but spread its
influence to the others. And while Winston watched
horrified, it unknowingly demonstrated this.
The captive Staff member was grabbed and held
by the others, its long arms and legs pulled
apart. The huddled group lifted it up off the
floor, so it couldn’t free itself and run off
into the endless aisles of furniture. Wearing
SCP-035, the leader extended an arm, black ooze
dripping from it, the droplets burning holes
in the floor as it reached towards the faceless
head of the restrained Staff member. It placed a
large hand over the faceless head of the captive,
more of the corrosive secretion passing onto
the new addition to SCP-035’s growing army.
As the black substance spread over the Staff
member, so did the influence of the Possessive
Mask force its way into another vessel.
“I’m telling you; I know what I saw!”
Winston protested after recounting the events
to the other settlers back at Cookware. “There’s
something else out there, something new and
dangerous, and it’s infecting the Staff!”
“It’s ridiculous,” replied Bryce, one of the
survivors who’d been there much longer. “I’ve
been here for years, and I never even
heard of such a thing!” they yelled.
“I saw it with my own eyes,”
Winston argued. “It has a small
army of them already under its control.”
“Even if what you’re saying is true,” someone
else chimed in. “What does it matter? We’ve
already got barriers that keep the Staff out,
and they only attack at night anyway.
Surely, even if this mask thing really
is in control of them now, who cares?”
As if on cue, one of the lookouts at the
Cookware settlement started frantically trying
to get everyone’s attention. They pointed to
the ominous glow coming from just beyond the
nearby aisles filled with wardrobe frames. An
orange flicker was visible, even under the
lights of the store, which were still on,
although blocked a little by thick plumes of
black smoke rising up towards the ceiling.
“That’s Lighting,” the lookout said in
shocked disbelief, stating the name of
another nearby community of survivors that
was named after an Ikea store department.
“Something must’ve happened over there,”
Bryce declared. “Maybe it’s an electrical
fire that’s gotten out of control.”
“It’s them,” Winston said solemnly.
“It can’t be them!” the older survivor snapped.
“The lights are still on, it’s still daytime in
the store, and Staff never attack during the day.”
“I don’t think the rules are the same anymore!”
Winston argued frustratedly. “There’s
no telling what that mask did to them.”
“Perhaps…” Bryce was trying desperately to come
up with a suggestion, but was clearly grasping
at straws. “What if this mask can be reasoned
with? If it's more intelligent than the Staff,
we can… we can negotiate! There
must be something it wants!”
“What do you think it wants? It wants this
place, this Ikea. And now it has control of
enough Staff to form a small army. You think it’s
just gonna stop there? It’s coming for all of us,
and it won’t stop until it’s got this whole store
under its control! And if it has to wipe us out to
do that… well, it looks like it’s not hesitating.”
“So, what do we do?” a voice called meekly.
Winston turned to see the townsfolk of
Cookware had gathered, all looking up
at him with terrified expressions on their
faces. He gazed back at each one of them,
then looked back over at the smoke now
towering over where Lighting had been,
and was now in flames. Who knew how many of the
settlers there were still alive? And how long
would it be before SCP-035 and its new army did
the same to Cookware? Something had to be done.
“We need to get the word out!” Winston
announced to the other survivors. “I
need our fastest to run over to the other
towns in the store. You each take one,
you pass on the message, and then you come back.
You know your way around well enough, so avoid
anywhere you’d normally see Staff. Even if they
haven’t been corrupted, we can’t chance it.”
“What do we tell the other settlements?”
somebody in the crowd called.
“You tell them what’s going on. You say that
something has come here to threaten this Ikea,
and our way of life. This place isn’t where
any of us first came from, but it’s all of our
home now. It’s provided for us, but now it
needs us to defend it,” Winston explained.
“And how exactly are we going
to do that?” Bryce asked.
The lights had gone out, but although night
had fallen, it wasn’t dark yet. Standing with
their fellow survivors from numerous other
settlements, the residents of SCP-3008 had
fashioned flaming torches from the legs of
Ikea desks and tables. And that wasn’t all.
They were carrying makeshift weapons. Some had
spears crafted using curtain rails with sharp
kitchen implements fashioned to the end. Others
had wardrobe doors in their hands to act as
rudimentary shields. They were hardly warriors,
but as an army of corrupted Staff members
lurched out of the darkness towards them, each
survivor of SCP-3008 knew what they had to do.
At the front of its army, towered the Staff member
with SCP-035 on its faceless head. The Possessive
Mask’s wide grin had shifted, now a long frown,
almost one of disgust at the amassed settlers
who opposed it. As it raised an elongated arm
to command its horde, Winston raised a curtain
rail spear into the air.
“FOR IKEA!” he yelled,
as the residents of SCP-3008 charged.
Want to own an SCP of your own? Go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “WHAT IF SCP-343 WORE
SCP-035?” and “SCP-173 SURPRISES SCP-3008
SHOPPERS” for more anomalous surprises!